other houses chose dragons
Krakens and lions for their sigils we
Tully's took the trout that most
terrifying us fish especially when it
leaps out of the water I suppose you
don't have many options when you live in
the Riverlands have been worse if we
could have been minnows or tweat after
all we make a lot of it though a land
doesn't get as fertile as hours just by
water the Old River Kings storm Kings
and the kings of the rock spilled blood
here for thousands of years squabbling
like children over a new toy until the
Ironborn came and spanked them with
their axes under her on the black their
kingdom stretched all the way to the
gods eye where they built the largest
castle Westeros had ever seen maesters
teach that Haran was a fool but he had
some sense if you're going to enslave
and torture an entire people you best
have thick walls to hide behind but the
very day the last stone was laid in
Harrenhal Aegon Targaryen landed in
Westeros as soon as he saw a Kahn's host
on the horizon my ancestor Edmund led
the mass desertion of river Lords to
Aegon side I don't have an even noticed
the problem with huge castles as they
blind you to what's outside books by the
size and the arrogance they inspire
not that the iron ball never lacked for
that they take pride in their ignorance
of every trapping of civilization now
any Baker could have told them that fire
turn stone walls into an oven and so
harren the black finally lived up to his
name and the river Lord
swept the Ironborn back to the sea in
return per Edmunds service house Tully
was made egg ons new Lord paramount of
the Trident and all the other lords had
to swear us fealty but old habits die
hard the river lands are and always have
been the middle child of Westeros
caught up in every fart from one Lord at
another my ancestors knew that for the
Tully's to survive
alliances must be made our trout has
swum up so many rivers over the
centuries and lepton to so many plates
that it's a wonder half the realms
sigils don't have fins by now thus every
Tully child is taught family duty honor
the Tully words and pains in the Tully
ass when I returned from the war of the
ninepenny kings people called me sir
Brendan but my older brother Hosler
called me engaged a great match with a
very rich house to be sure but I just
fought and killed the great dealer men
and had no desire to be told when and
whom to marry
I broke ties with him earning the name
blackfish along with my personal sigil a
much more intimidating black trout
I was too stubborn at the time to
realize that while other houses fight
with swords house Tully fights with
marriages then my knees catlins a
betrothal to Brandon stark Juris into
the war against the Mad King while my
other knee slices betrothal to Jon Arryn
cemented the rebellion
if I'd have obeyed my older brother
earlier we'd have had the largest Navy
in Westeros with us then as well and our
victory would have been Swift of course
I never mentioned this fact to my
brother you'd have taken it as an
apology my brother is dead now and my
nephew Edmure rules in Riverrun gods
help us a tribe that can't tell the worm
from the hook but he is a Tully and he
is unmarried and there is a war we all
know how this story ends maybe she'll be
beautiful maybe she'll be rich as long
as she brings swords and men to house
Tully she could look like the fish we
hang all over Riverrun he'll honor his
duty to family and swallow it one
blackfish per family can be overlooked -
and we'd have to change all those pretty
banners